Davos is currently swarming with
prostitutes ah yes Davos the annual
meeting in Switzerland where the global
Elite meet to suck each other off about
how much good they're doing and to
determine how they're gonna Lord over
you is also when prostitution in the
town skyrockets every year workers from
all over Europe migrate to Davos for the
week to make Bank how much Bank you ask
well a four-hour reservation with one of
these workers will run you about 1 600
want her to spend the night with you
that will cost you two thousand seven
hundred dollars but maybe you're not
into that kind of thing maybe you just
want someone pretty to accompany you to
dinner so you can impress your
colleagues there are agencies that offer
this kind of service too turns out the
seemingly Noble Elites aren't so Noble
after all which is why